citing their wily anonymous sources the
rumormongers have we got discovered are
reporting that warner brothers and DC
films have designs on making an else
world style film featuring a black
version of Batman and that the studio's
already have an actor in mind that actor
is Daniel Kaluga the heavyweight British
thespian who knows his way around a
comic book adaptation the star has
previously appeared as the super villain
Black Death in 2013's kick-ass 2 and as
with copy in 2018 s Black Panther you
may also recognize him from his lead
role in Jordan peels brilliant 2017
directorial debut get out or perhaps
from his appearance as poor lovelorn
Bingham Madsen in 15 million merits one
of the best and most brutal episodes of
Black Mirror there's no doubt that the
guy could make an amazing Batman since
he's as talented as actors come and has
demonstrated the necessary physicality
to take on a lead superhero role the
idea of a Batman story set outside the
DC e u--'s main continuity could also be
interesting just look at Joker which is
in no way connected to the other films
from the label and which was hailed by
many as one of the best films of last
year period as the whether there's
actually anything to this rumor though
suffice to say that we're highly
skeptical there is a precedent for a
black version of The Dark Knight in the
comics however DC Comics gave us the
black hero batwing a Bruce Wayne
sanctioned crime fighter operating in
the fictional city of Tanaka in the
Democratic Republic of the Congo the
character was introduced in Batman
Incorporated a series that saw Wayne
essentially tried to franchise the
symbol that is Batman and train various
operatives to carry on his legacy of
striking fear into the hearts of
criminals all over the world the batwing
suit which was designed by Lucius Fox
and which is armored and has limited
regeneration and flight capabilities was
first worn by David's up in May an
ex-soldier turned police officer
handpicked by Wayne to lead the fight
against the global terrorist
organization known as Leviathan after
the supervillain Massacre was revealed
to be some vim BAE's older brother he
resigned his batwing the next character
to take on the mantle was none other
than Luke Fox lucious's son this version
of the character has had slightly more
staying power and he's also appeared in
the animated film Batman bad blood the
DC icons novel Catwoman Soul Stealer and
the Mass
multiplayer online game DC Universe
Online Luke Fox even appears in the CW
series Batwoman portrayed by cameras
Johnson and although the character is
yet to suit up his batwing while the
thought of Kaluga stepping into the role
of batwing or an alternate Batman is
certainly enticing the unfortunate fact
is that we got this coverage report is
in all likelihood a bunch of malarkey
for one thing it simply doesn't make
sense on its surface for DC films to be
convoluting the Batman story at a time
when they're getting ready to bring the
first solo Batman film in almost a
decade to market with a rebooted version
of the character on which fans aren't
entirely sold yet for another even
though it's tough to argue with the else
world style approach in the wake of
joker's billion-dollar success there
have been no announcements concerning
any such projects even in the vaguest
terms pair this with the fact that no
other media outlets out there other than
we got this covered or reporting on this
rumor and were left with a strong
possibility that the website sources are
as they often tend to be not entirely
sound we suppose it's possible though
that some executive somewhere will catch
wind of this rumor think it sounds like
a pretty good idea and jot down a note
reading kouya batwing for their next
pitch meeting in the meantime we'll just
look forward to the actors next project
he'll be starring as political black
panther Fred Hampton in the as yet
untitled biopic currently in
post-production and slated for release
later this year check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]